ha pasado casi un año saben casi un año
hace casi un año hablé desde el castillo
real aquí en Varsovia sólo semanas
después de que Vladimir Putin hubiera
desatado su asalto asesino y sangriento
sobre Ucrania la mayor guerra terrestre
en Europa desde la Segunda Guerra
Mundial
eso marcó su inicio y los principios que
han sido la base de la paz la
prosperidad y la estabilidad en este
planeta por más de 75 años
estuvieron en riesgo de ser destruidos
hace un año
el mundo estaba
preocupándose por la caída de quien Pero
acabo de llegar de y por lo reportar que
quiere sigue fuerte
que sigue siendo orgullosa y está firme
por encima de todo sigue libre
cuando Rusia invadió no fue solamente
una prueba parocrania sino para todo el
mundo
Europa estaba bajo prueba Estados Unidos
estaba bajo prueba la otan estaba bajo
prueba todas las democracias estaban
siendo confrontadas y las preguntas que
se nos hacían eran simples así como
profundas que respondimos
responderíamos miraríamos al otro lado
seremos fuertes o débiles
seríamos estaríamos Unidos o divididos
con nuestros aliados un año después
conocemos la respuesta respondimos
fuimos fuertes fuimos Unidos y el mundo
no miro al otro lado
también enfrentamos dudas fundamentales
sobre el compromiso
a los principios sobre a los principios
más básicos
respetaríamos y defenderíamos la
soberanía de las Naciones el derecho a
la gente a ser libre de unas agresiones
extranjeras defenderíamos la democracia
un año después
sabemos las respuestas Y sí estuvimos
firmes por la soberanía
defendimos el derecho a la gente de
vivir libre ante la agresión lo hicimos
defendimos la democracia
ayer tuve el honor de estar del lado del
presidente es el para declarar
que Seguiremos defendiendo los mismos
valores sin importar lo que ocurra
cuando el presidente Putin ordenó que
sus tanques entraran a Ucrania él pensó
que íbamos a dejar que entraran y él
estaba muy equivocado
El pueblo ucraniano era fue demasiado
valiente Estados Unidos Europa una
coalición de Naciones del Atlántico al
Pacífico
estábamos unificados la democracia Fue
bastante fuerte en vez de una victoria
fácil
que pudo haber predecido Putin abandonó
tanques incendiados y fuerzas
desorganizadas él pensó que hubiera el
pensó que iba a obtener la vandalización
de lo tan sin embargo filandia se unió
Suecia se unió pensó que la otan se iba
a facturar y se iba a dividir en vez de
eso la otan estuvo mucho más unida
que nunca antes
él pensó que podía hacer de la energía
un arma para vencer la determinación
europea en vez de eso trabajamos junto
con Europa para acabar con la
dependencia de los combustibles fósiles
de Rusia pensó que los autócratas como
él iban a ser rudos y fuertes y que los
líderes de la Democracia iban a ser
débiles pero luego enfrentó la voluntad
de hierro de Estados Unidos y Europa que
impidió ser gobernados por el temor y la
fuerza por una nación liderada
el presidente se defendió con fuerza con
todo su pueblo el presidente Putin fue
confrontado con algo que no creyó que
fuera posible hace un año la democracia
en el mundo se ha hecho cada vez más
fuerte no más débil los autócratas del
mundo se han hecho más débiles no más
fuertes
porque los momentos de Gran
incertidumbre
saber lo que uno defiende es mucho más
importante saber quién está del lado de
uno marca una diferencia completamente
el pueblo de Polonia lo sabe Y ustedes
lo saben
ustedes lo saben mejor que nadie aquí en
Polonia
eso es lo que significa la solidaridad
a través de la opresión cuando ciudades
hermosas fueron destruidas después de
Las Guerras después de
El yugo del comunismo Polonia sobrevivió
porque ustedes estaban juntos Así es
como los líderes Valientes de la
oposición de biela Rusia y otros países
siguen luchando por su democracia Así es
como la determinación del pueblo de
moldoba sigue actuando
la
determinación de los molubanos para
vivir en libertad
los están caminando a la membresía de la
Unión Europea presidente de salud está
aquí Hoy no sé si ella está aquí en
estos momentos pero quiero que sepa que
soy de su lado
en la búsqueda de la libertad por el
pueblo de moldea por favor de Luna Ronda
de aplausos
[Música]
un año después del inicio de esta guerra
Putin ya no duda de la fortaleza de
nuestra coalición él duda de nuestras
convicciones todavía duda de nuestra
permanencia en el poder duda de nuestro
respaldo por Ucrania
duda que la otan pueda permanecer
unificada pero no debe haber ninguna
duda nuestro respaldo por Ucrania no
cesará la otan no será dividida y
nosotros no nos agotaremos
el deseo de Putin por tierra
se enfrentó con el amor del pueblo
ucraniano por la tierra el mundo seguirá
defendiendo la libertad hoy mañana y por
siempre
eso es lo que está en juego acá la
libertad
Ese es el mensaje que les llevé aquí
ayer directamente al pueblo ucraniano
cuando el presidente se le esqui dice
que llega a los Estados Unidos en
diciembre
cito la lucha definirá al mundo
y la manera en la que vivirá nuestros
hijos y nietos y luego sus hijos y sus
nietos él no solamente hablaba de los
niños o los nietos en Ucrania él hablaba
de todos nuestros niños y nietos los
suyos Y los míos
estamos viendo hoy lo que el pueblo de
Polonia lo que el pueblo en toda Europa
vio por décadas
apetito de la autocracia no puede ser
apaciguado debe ser opuesto los
autócratas solo entienden una palabra y
es el no no no no no
no van a tomarse mi país No van a
tomarselos a libertad ni nuestro futuro
voy a repetir anoche esta noche lo que
dije el año pasado el mismo lugar
un dictador nunca será capaz de
apaciguar el amor del pueblo por la
libertad la brutalidad nunca disminuirá
la voluntad de Los libres
y Ucrania
Ucrania nunca será una victoria para
Rusia nunca
la gente libre se niega a vivir en un
mundo de desesperanza y de oscuridad
Este ha sido un año extraordinario en
cualquier sentido
extraordinario en brutalidad por parte
de las fuerzas y mercenarios rusos han
cometido
crímenes en contra de la humanidad
sin ningún tipo de
vergüenza han llevado muerte y
destrucción a los civiles
han utilizado la violación como un arma
de guerra
han robado niños ucranianos en un
intento
de eliminar el futuro de Ucrania han
bombardeado estaciones de tren
hospitales de maternidad escuelas
orfanatos nadie
Nadie puede mirar al otro lado ante las
atrocidades rusas en contra del pueblo
ucraniano esto es aborrecible como
mínimo pero extraordinariamente a sí
mismo
ha llegado la respuesta por parte del
pueblo ucraniano y por parte del mundo
un año después de que las bombas
empezaron a caer los tanques rusos
llegaron a Ucrania
Ucrania sigue siendo independiente y
libre
de personas los ucranianos han luchado
para reclamar su tierra más de 50% del
territorio que Rusia sostenía el año
pasado
la bandera
azul y amarilla encontró la manera de
recuperarlo el presidente es el lensky
sigue liderando Un gobierno democrático
elegido por el pueblo que representa la
voluntad de los ucranianos
el mundo ya ha votado varias veces
incluyendo la asamblea general de
Naciones Unidas para condenar la
agresión rusa y el respaldo a una paz
justa es momento
en momentos esta votación ha sido
avasallante en octubre 143 naciones de
las Naciones Unidas condenaron La
anexión ilegal de Rusia solamente cuatro
cuatro en todas las Naciones Unidas
votaron a favor de Rusia 4
esta noche
hablo de nuevo al pueblo de Rusia
Estados Unidos y las naciones de Europa
no buscan controlar o destruir a Rusia
el oeste no quiere atacar a Rusia como
Putin dijo hoy millones de ciudadanos
rusos solamente quieren vivir en paz con
sus vecinos ellos no son el enemigo esta
guerra nunca ha sido una necesidad es
una tragedia el presidente Putin eligió
esta guerra
Cada día que la guerra continúa es por
su elección él puede terminar la guerra
con una palabra es simple si Rusia deja
de invadir a Ucrania es el fin de la
guerra
si Ucrania deja de defenderse de Rusia
será el fin de Ucrania
por eso es que juntos estamos asegurando
los de cruzcrania pueda defenderse a sí
misma los Estados Unidos
ha sembrado una ha ensamblado una
coalición mundial de más de 50 naciones
para llevar armas y suministros críticos
a los combatientes ucranianos valerosos
en la línea de enfrente defensas aéreas
artillería munición tanques vehículos
armados la Unión Europea y sus estados
miembros han aumentado sus
contribuciones sin ningún precedente
comprometidos con colocar No solamente
la asistencia de seguridad sino
asistencia económica humanitaria tantos
tanto respaldo más y a todos ustedes hoy
Tómese un momento
estoy hablando en serio Cuando digo esto
mírense miren a los lados celular al
otro miren en lo que han log miren lo
que han logrado hasta este momento
Polonia está recibiendo más de 1.5
millones de refugiados de esta guerra
los bendiga
la generosidad polaca la voluntad de
abrir corazones y hogares es
extraordinaria el pueblo estadounidense
está Unido en esta determinación también
en todo mi país grandes ciudades
pequeñas ciudades la bandera ucraniana
vuelan en hogares estadounidenses está
ondeando durante el año pasado de los
demócratas y los republicanos en el
congreso de Estados Unidos se han
reunido para defender la libertad eso es
lo que los estadounidenses hacen
el mundo también se está reuniendo para
enfrentar
las consecuencias de la guerra de Putin
Putin trató de matar de hambre al mundo
bloqueando los puertos del mar Negro
para impedir que Ucrania exportar a su
grano exacerbando una crisis global
mundial en los países de desarrollo en
África que ha afectado particularmente
los países en desarrollo en África en
vez de eso Estados Unidos y el g7 con
sus socios alrededor del mundo ha
respondido al llamado con un compromiso
histórico para enfrentar esta crisis y
para fortalecer los suministros
alimenticios mundiales de esta manera mi
esposa
estaba viajando a África para llevar la
atención a ese tema crítico nuestro
compromiso es con el pueblo de Ucrania y
con el futuro de Ucrania
una Ucrania es libre soberana
democrática
miles de ustedes declararon
hace 30 años se declaró independencia de
Ucrania ellos la revolución naranja la
revolución de la dignidad
ellos se enfrentaron
la guerra del Don miles murieron allá
ellos siguen tratando de combatir los
esfuerzos de kremlin es un sueño para
Los Patriotas ucranianos que lucharon
durante años en contra de la agresión
rusa en el donbas
y contra y para los héroes que han dado
todo que han dado sus vidas
el servicio de su amado Ucrania me honró
mucho visitar el Memorial
para pagar un tributo al sacrificio de
aquellos que han perdido sus vidas
al lado del presidente
los Estados Unidos y sus aliados están
respaldando a todos las personas en
Ucrania que trabajan
profesores asistentes
los que mantienen la energía aprendida a
pesar de estos bombardeos crueles de
Rusia estamos del lado de los miles de
refugiados en esta guerra que han
encontrado a una Europa que les dio la
bienvenida aquí en Polonia ella en
Estados Unidos en toda Europa la gente
hizo lo que podía hacer para ayudarlos y
sigue haciéndolo los negocios polacos la
sociedad civil los líderes culturales
incluyendo la primera dama de Polonia
que está aquí hoy han liderado con su
corazón y con su con su determinación
mostrando lo importante y lo bello del
espíritu humano señora ama todos La
amamos Muchas gracias
nunca olvidaré las visitas del año
pasado de los refugiados de Ucrania que
acaban de llegar a Ucrania viendo sus
rostros su cansancio su miedo
sosteniendo a sus hijos muy de cerca
preocupados de que no pudieran volver a
ver a sus esposos padres hijos en esos
momentos tan Duros de la vida ustedes el
pueblo de Polonia les ofreció seguridad
una luz los abrazaron literalmente yo
pude verlo pude ver la mirada en sus
rostros
Mientras tanto juntos nos aseguramos de
que Rusia estuviera pagando el precio
por sus abusos seguíamos manteniendo las
mayores sanciones impuestas nunca sobre
cualquier país en la historia
y vamos a anunciar más sanciones esta
semana juntos con nuestros socios
haremos que aquellos responsables por la
guerra sean responsables buscaremos
justicia para los crímenes de guerra y
en contra de la humanidad que siguen
siendo cometidos por parte de los rusos
saben
hay más razones para estar orgulloso
para estar orgullosos por lo que hemos
logrado el año pasado pero tenemos que
ser honestos
a medida que miramos al año que viene
la defensa de la libertad no es el
trabajo de un solo día o de un solo año
siempre es difícil y siempre es
importante
y Ucrania sigue defendiéndose ante la
agresión rusa y una contraofensiva
Esto va a seguir siendo difícil iba a
seguir siendo agrio
va a haber tragedias pero Ucrania sigue
lista para la lucha que viene Estados
Unidos junto con sus aliados y socios
van a seguir
respaldando Ucrania mientras se defiende
el próximo año
yo recibiré a cada miembro de la otan
esa Cumbre 224 en Estados Unidos para
nuestra compra 2024 celebramos en el
aniversario El quinto aniversario de la
mayor Alianza en la historia del mundo
que es
dotán que no haya ninguna duda
compromiso de Estados Unidos con la
alianza de la otan y el artículo 5 es
sólido
cada miembro de la otan lo sabe Rusia lo
sabe también
un ataque en contra es un ataque en
contra de todos es un juramento sagrado
un juramento sagrado para defender cada
pulgada del territorio de la otan
en el último año los Estados Unidos se
han reunido con aliados y socios en una
coalición extraordinaria para defenderse
de la agresión rusa para el trabajo que
viene
no es solamente pensar en lo que
enfrentamos sino en lo que buscamos qué
tipo de mundo queremos construir
necesitamos tomar estas fortalezas y
estas habilidades y aplicarlas para
levantar para mejorar las vidas de las
personas mejorar la salud aumentar la
prosperidad construir paz y seguridad
tratar con dignidad a todos con respeto
para todos esa es nuestra
responsabilidad las democracias del
mundo tienen que cumplirle al pueblo
mientras estamos reunidos hoy el mundo
está en un punto de inflexión las
decisiones que tomamos de aquí a los
próximos cinco años van a determinar y
dar forma a nuestras vidas por décadas
es cierto para los estadounidenses es
cierto para el pueblo para la gente del
mundo mientras
las decisiones debemos tomarlas nosotros
y son nuestras los principios y lo que
está en juegos es eterno la decisión
entre el caos y la estabilidad entre la
construcción y la destrucción entre la
esperanza y el miedo entre la democracia
que aumenta el espíritu humano y la mano
brutal del dictador que lo aplasta
entre nada menos que la limitación y las
posibilidades
el tipo de posibilidades que vienen
cuando la gente que vive no en
cautiverio sino en Libertad Libertad
no hay una palabra más dulce que la
libertad
no hay una meta más noble que la
libertad de una aspiración más grande
que la libertad
Estados Unidos sabe esto ustedes lo
saben y todo lo que hacemos ahora debe
ser hecho para que nuestros hijos y
nietos sepan también como nosotros de la
libertad el enemigo es el tirano
Esta es la esperanza para nuestra era la
libertad
Pónganse de nuestro lado Nosotros
defenderemos
movámonos con fe y convicción con el
compromiso de ser aliados
no de la oscuridad sino de la luz no de
la opresión sino de la libertad no del
cautiverio sino de verdad de la libertad
que Dios los bendiga a todos Que Dios
proteja a nuestras tropas y que Dios
bendiga a los héroes de Ucrania y a
todos aquellos que defienden la Libertad
en todo el mundo Muchas gracias Polonia
muchas muchas gracias por lo que están
haciendo Dios los bendiga a todos
[Aplausos]